there's an app for that
wait hold on i'm steve jobs
it was a phrase so ubiquitous in the
early days of the smartphone craze that
it's hard to believe apple actually has
trademarked it was a testament to a
simple and immutable truth about the
world these new touch screen phones were
creating no matter how strange and
obscure the need there would be an app
to fulfill it perhaps you remember ibear
the app that allowed you to pretend you
were drinking a tall glass of beer for
some reason there was car matey an app
that reminded you where you parked your
car in a pirate voice and who could
forget i am bread a surreal game about
controlling a sentient slice of bread on
a quest to become toast but there's one
app out there somewhere on the market
that you probably didn't download and if
you did well you have our sincerest
apologies because even seeing this video
pop out onto your feed probably sent a
chill down your spine well if that chill
ever even left take it from one
gentleman whose life took a very strange
turn after downloading a certain app
that the scp foundation calls
scp-1471 because the sentiment there's
an app for that doesn't exclude
experiencing mortal terror joe lillis an
insurance salesman from milwaukee had
just gone through another atrocious date
after a mediocre meal and an
uncomfortable 35 minutes of inane babble
sensing the whole time that she really
wasn't that interested his date excused
himself to take a quick phone call
outside sadly for joe she never returned
leaving him to pick up the check of all
the many words you could use to describe
poor joe louis the most pertinent would
be lonely ever since carol his wife of
10 years had passed away in a freak
accident he'd been trying to find some
kind of way to fill the void they'd been
high school sweethearts intent on
spending the rest of their lives with
one another as fate would have it only
carol would get that tainted luxury joe
would be forced to endure life after the
joy of living had run its course he only
hoped he might be lucky enough to find
love again however joe was on the wrong
side of 40 and as so many others his age
were already hitched he could feel his
options going out one by one would he be
destined to live out the rest of his
days alone joe didn't feel like spending
the back half of his life catching
reruns of seinfeld and tending to his
fish he needed to get out there and
thankfully like the rest of us he lived
in the internet age he had more apps
websites online services and hot russian
singles in his area than he knew what to
do with so surely one would have the
right person for him he tried them all
tinder hinge match.com plenty of fish
eharmony bumble zeusk okcupid friend
finder deeply lonely singles with low
expectations.com
and so much more however all it seemed
to achieve was setting him up for more
disappointment none of the dates he'd
managed to get ever resulted in anything
getting serious heck it was a minor
miracle if he even managed to get any of
them on a second date was this it was
this his life now had he only ever
gotten one shot at love and the grasping
claws of fate yanked it away from him
without a second thought would life
continue on the hamster wheel of
loneliness sleeping getting up eating
working and sleeping again every day
getting somehow both faster and slower
as life trudged on to a disappointing
yet inevitable conclusion what a
terrible fate to find yourself trapped
in whenever joe started feeling maudlin
like this he knew it was time to get
proactive again maybe the right woman
was out there there were billions of
them after all surely at least one of
them would be the perfect person for him
he just needed the perfect app he'd burn
through all of the most reputable apps
already and was now perusing some of the
slightly seedier options most of which
were likely data mining fronts from the
vulcans however as generic app after
generic app passed something different
caught his eye the icon was a smiling
cartoon dog and its name was mal version
1.0.0
this gave him a little chuckle at the
very least it was very different
branding from the rest of the dating
apps he'd seen maybe it just been sorted
into the wrong section of the app store
he decided he'd check it out and take a
look at the app's description the
description read never settle for those
awkward feelings of being alone ever
again malo is an exciting and
interactive experience
that will keep you engaged and intrigued
the anxiety of social situations can be
nerve-wracking but after just a few
hours of mellow you will soon forget all
about those painful emotions of
disappointment be part of the new craze
that is quickly becoming the next social
substitute remember the more you
participate the more mallow will engage
you
your experience is completely up to you
absolutely no ads
well it certainly provoked joe's
curiosity at the very least he did want
to banish his feelings of loneliness and
seeing as the app was free and
apparently had no ads he'd surely be
foolish to not at least give it a whirl
what's the worst that could happen he
began the installation and only then
noticed that the app had no listed
developer it took up 9.8 megabytes of
memory which he wasn't tech savvy enough
to see any issues with more than
anything joe was just enticed by the
prospect of finally having another
chance at companionship with mallow
after all it is the next social
substitute whatever that means however
joe's excitement was quickly quashed
when he hit the home screen button and
noticed that the icon for the app never
actually materialized strange he checked
the app store portal again and saw that
according to them the app had completely
downloaded what gives was it a glitch or
was malo actually just malware either
way he was disheartened by the fact that
this immaterial app certainly wouldn't
be getting him any companionship or so
he thought anyway joe was used to
disappointment by now so he didn't take
it too personally he decided to just
play out the rest of his evening on
autopilot making himself some soup doing
the laundry watching more seinfeld
reruns taking a cold shower and
preparing to cry himself to sleep again
mallow was already becoming a distant
memory just like all the deceptive
sources of home but one strange thing
happened that disrupted joe's finely
tuned evening routine he received a text
message this was incredibly strange
because nobody ever seemed to text him
the last text he got was from carol just
before her accident so it was almost
surreal to hear that alert sound now
after everything that happened he
checked and saw that the text was an
image attachment sent from an unknown
number perplexed yet curious he decided
to open it his curiosity soon gave way
to a kind of melancholy nostalgia when
he saw that the photo was of his and
carol's favorite cafe in town they'd
spent many a morning there back when she
was alive treating themselves to a nice
cup of coffee and perhaps a croissant
just seeing it again caused an
involuntary smile to spread across his
face it never even occurred to him as it
probably would have to others that this
could be seen as a little creepy he
hadn't frequented the bakery since carol
died how would anyone even know that
this place held any significance for him
was it a stalker a ghost or just a
spooky coincidence none of these
thoughts even crossed joe's mind he was
just grateful for the surprising
reminder of the happiness he'd once had
for the next couple hours things seemed
lighter he went about his evening
checking the photo every so often and
smiling until eventually he found
himself in bed still looking into the
glow of his phone it was such a
beautiful little cafe then he froze he
noticed something in the picture he'd
been there the whole time but only now
he was seeing rather than just looking
it was in the corner staring through the
glass of the cafe store so faint he
almost wanted to dismiss it as a trick
of the light it was a face well not a
face
more like a skull not a human not
anywhere near human long slender and
canine with protruding fangs and vacant
white eyes the pure white of the skull
was buried in a nest of thick black hair
it looked like it was crouching behind
the door looking out and grinning
whatever the hell it was
just seeing it change the entire tone of
the picture it was no longer a simple
reminder of bygone joy now all that was
radiating out of that image was a
palpable sense of dread was someone
playing some kind of awful prank on him
just then he was jogged from his
contemplation by another alert a new
message from the same number as before
with great hesitation he hovered his
thumb over the push notification and
clicked that's when everything got a lot
worse it was a photo of a bus stop not
just any bus stop of course it was stop
c-16 the one that joe always took to get
to work it looked like it was taken
relatively early in the morning but
nobody was there well
not quite nobody there was that figure
again it stood at full height behind the
partially frosted glass that makes up
the back of the bus stop the same large
black humanoid shape with a white
grinning dog skull where the face should
be something about it terrified him on
such a primal level like the way our
lizard brain reacts to some ancient apex
predator and whatever this thing was it
clearly knew something about him how
else could it stage all these photos joe
got out of bed and looked out of the
window down onto his dark front street
empty thankfully but after this surprise
nightmare he wasn't going to take any
chances he grabbed a kitchen knife from
downstairs and placed it on his bedside
cabinet right next to his phone with
9-1-1 on speed dial joe lillis a
43-year-old man slept with the lights on
that night for the first time in over 30
years sadly for him the nightmare was
just beginning the next morning joe woke
up unharmed but he wasn't pleased to see
that he'd gotten several more texts in
his sleep there was one taken outside of
the local insurance company office where
he worked the strange creature with the
skull for a face was looming around the
corner peering at the camera with its
lipless grin like it was mocking him
another photo was taken at the local
supermarket where joe did most of his
grocery shopping the frame was
centralized on the cereal aisle bordered
on both sides by walls of garish mascots
endlessly repeated down at the far end
of the aisle was a looming dark figure
with that cold canine skull where a
human face should be there were a few
more but worst of all was the last one
it was taken at the cemetery in the
foreground a headstone reading carol
lillis beloved wife and daughter joe was
horrified to see that skull-faced beast
was rising up behind his wife's grave
long clawed fingers curling around the
top of the headstone that was the moment
that joe decided to go to the police
about all of this before things got even
more out of hand he called an uber to
get down to the station he certainly
didn't feel like he was going anywhere
near his regular bus stop after last
night he showed the photos he'd been
sent so far to an officer posted at the
station and they agreed that there was
certainly something strange about it
while the behavior undeniably bordered
on harassment it hadn't yet delved into
criminal territory so he would sadly be
on his own until then the best they
could do was stay in touch and kept
abreast of any new developments the only
sage advice they could give him was not
to delete the photos as they could
always be used as evidence in court
later if things escalated this was
literally the last result that joe
wanted out of this considering how
bizarre and threatening things were
getting already he really didn't want to
find out what escalation looked like in
this case but what else could he do but
carry on just trying to exercise as much
caution as he could in these strange new
circumstances he went to work and tried
his best to stay productive despite the
fact that every three or so hours a new
photo would arrive places that he liked
to sit in the local parks stores he'd
frequent restaurants he liked to eat at
the nightmare skeleton dog thing would
be standing in all of them just mugging
for the camera on one hand every time he
looked at one of the photos joe felt
like he was giving this freak exactly
what they wanted on the other hand how
could he possibly look away what if he
missed something that could save his
life it carried on much like that until
later in the evening joe may have not
been a genius but he was no fool either
he'd seen too many of those seedy true
crime documentaries about kidnapping to
take his normal route home he took a
real detour frequently checking over his
shoulder the entire time much to his
relief he didn't see anything out of
place good when he got home he locked
every door and bolted every window
nothing would be getting the jump on him
tonight that's when the next picture
came in a photograph of joe's empty
office cubicle with the bony face of the
creature looming over the divider with a
grin he could feel his heart pounding
away in his chest just looking at it how
did this thing get around like this how
was it able to infiltrate everywhere in
his entire goddamn life suddenly he felt
a smile spreading across his face this
freak had just messed up big time before
all these creepy photos had been taken
in public places but the one taken in
his office oh this crossed the line into
trespassing the police would have to do
something about it now it had given him
an ace up his sleeve that confidence
faded a few hours later when he received
another photo this time it was the skull
face monster just standing on the
sidewalk the sidewalk that joe
remembered walking on his covert
alternative route he could feel himself
break into a cold sweat it seemed
whoever this was he really did hold no
secrets from them now more than ever joe
didn't feel safe in his own home so you
can only imagine how he felt when a few
hours later he received a photo of the
skull-faced stalker standing right
outside his own front door staring into
the camera it sent him rushing to the
window again to check outside but of
course nobody was there the next day
when he called the police and updated
them on the situation they told him that
they were doing all they could the best
thing he could possibly do was to remain
calm but vigilant he needed to keep an
eye on the photos being sent to him so
he could notify them if ever he was in
any immediate danger this put poor joe's
paranoia at a fever pitch even when he
went to work surrounded by his
co-workers by witnesses he could
scarcely tear his eyes away from his
phone he was a slave to the photos
forever waiting for the next one only to
experience crushing regret when the
photo actually arrived it looked like it
was taken moments before it was sent to
him joe saw himself looking at his own
phone in his office cubicle with that
huge skull-faced figure looming behind
him he screamed out loud upon seeing it
and turned to see if anything was behind
him but of course there was nothing
there the police inspected the office
talked to potential witnesses and
analyzed the photo it showed no signs of
any photographic manipulation but there
were also no witnesses around the office
who claimed to see anything strange that
day there was also no security camera
footage in the last several days that
showed this figure coming in or out joe
lillis started to feel like he was going
insane and perhaps he was but that
didn't change the tangible and
ever-present feeling that he was in
great danger he didn't come into work
the next day he'd receive more photos
like that in the night of himself taken
in real time with that skull face freak
looming he didn't want to leave the
house he didn't want to go anywhere
anymore he just didn't feel safe out
there how could he with all this madness
unfolding there was a time where he
could have said something like at least
it only seems confined to my phone he
might have even suspected that it had
something to do with that strange mellow
app he downloaded a few days prior that
hadn't seemed to do anything but this
situation had evolved since then he
wasn't just seeing the creature in
photos anymore it was here he kept
seeing quick flashes of it on the other
side of windows in reflections in the
corner of his eyes always darting away
if ever he turned towards it it was
everywhere and nowhere it was here just
for him he just knew
the police couldn't help nobody could
help joe just sat in the corner of his
bedroom clutching his kitchen knife
afraid to close his eyes it could be
anywhere it could be anywhere it could
be anywhere we know one thing for sure
joe lillis never felt truly alone ever
again he always had his new friend
waiting just out of sight and if ever
you're feeling lonesome and decide to
download mallow version 1.0.0 yourself
then you'll never feel lonely again
either now go check out
scp-1025 encyclopedia of common diseases
and worse ways to die scp edition for
more scps that'll creep into your mind
and give you nightmares